i love this country oprah i'm not trying
to avoid my taxes i was going to pay my
taxes oprah yeah you know i know you was
i was i was i know you was but then the
album flopped aha
so the album flop so we actually didn't
uh we didn't i don't even think you know
the way it's written i don't even think
it doesn't even sound like you were
trying to avoid your taxes you're just
like you don't even know you're supposed
to be paying yourself yeah i wasn't
paying attention to that kind of stuff
okay i i know you're up with your taxes
now we know that for sure okay so right
before fresh prince of bel-air i think
people would be surprised to know this
is the first time i realized this is
that you basically lost everything the
government seized your cars it took your
home you ended up in jail and you
describe it in two words actually rock
bottom rock bottom what was at the root
of that downfall will
you know what it's like and the life
lesson you took from it so
so what what you know when it rains it
pours yeah right so
um
you know getting into the the fight at
the radio station that you know i'm
charlie punching the dude that landed me
in jail so the money is gone the car's
gone i'm laying on the floor
in a jail cell and i'm like
you've got to be kidding me
i want a grammy eight months ago
right like what is happening
and
it's just that just that
the spiral when it when
when it starts going the other way
it's like sometimes you just have to get
out the way and just
wait till the the the you know the
downward spiral stops but it's a spiral
that you make so very clear and will
that you created yes and now you can see
it yourself you see how
the energy of yourself
everything that you were doing created
that exact moment yeah i talk about the
the idea of natural destruction versus
self-destruction yeah
and
you know
impermanence is the law of the the
universe so things are going to
deteriorate everything's going to grow
it's going to deteriorate and die and
you got to be ready to make the next
thing and that's natural right so we all
have to contend with the the entropy of
the
the universe in that way that's why it's
such a crime when you do it to yourself
it's like and that's when you hate
yourself the most
i love when you say this though there's
a strange thing that happens when
somebody falls your demise somehow
proves to everybody you ever disagreed
with that they were right
and you were wrong they develop a
smugness and seem to get a brutal
enjoyment out of the fact that god is
finally punishing you people tend to
have a schizophrenic relationship with
winners if you're down too long you
become an underdog and they feel
impelled to root for you but if you're
ever unfortunate enough to be up too
long you better get it hell no
[Laughter]
amen to that
don't we know that yes yes absolutely
that's one of the things that i hope
people can take away from the book when
you see the
that's that's you know like that's
you're not going to get around that yep
that you're not going to get around the
rise and fall and arise and fall of
you just got to be able to hold on to
yourself just got to be able to hold on
and it's like it's
endure when it's time to endure enjoy
when it's time to enjoy
you know but you're not going to get
around the ups and downs of that and you
know it took me a few of them to realize
that
um
it's not because i'm stupid
it's not because i'm weak it's not
because i'm a coward it's not it's not
any of that it's like
that's what life is yeah yeah that's
what it is
you know and all of those things are the
the natural ebb and flow and the natural
rise and fall
and
if we can relax
you know and settle into it then we can
enjoy
you know when the springtime is there
and we just buckle down when the winter
comes but we're not going to be able to
get around seasons
you